[Applause]
another movie with two women that i've
always loved uh might be coming back
lisa kudrow is teasing us drew barrymore
entertainment weekly reports she
recently said she'd be totally on board
for a new romy and michelle part two
please my favorite movie ever
well this comes after remember she and
mira servino showed up at the sag awards
and did like a little skit together the
movie believe it or not is 25 years old
but for my money it is still one of the
best rom-coms comedies films of all time
and do you know this is a true story i
was dating somebody in high school
and we went to go see romy and
michelle's high school union and they
didn't like it and i broke up with them
because
if you don't like that movie it's not
going to work out with us i love when
they love the two guys or casey deegan
and drama club they're like why didn't
why weren't they into us and like they
go into the yearbook and they're like
totally macking on each other i know i
would die for that movie for that and if
they brought it back i mean like a
streamer has to do it or they could do
like one of those mini series like and
just like that give us a few yeah but
somehow it has to come back do you agree
you guys do would you like this yes a
million people my daughters and i
watched that movie all the time all
right one next up
we're gonna talk about brain clutter uh
anyone ever get that brain clutter we're
just like
when your brain is swimming with all
those tiny little to do's that we just
can't seem to get done you know like
return you gotta return you gotta repair
that you gotta send a text uh well we
have a secret weapon now huffpost
reports a writer named serena wolfe
calls this list of small to do's the
needle list and here's how she
recommends that you tackle it she sets
aside 30 minutes to an hour every single
friday not every day just every friday
to blast through the needle list like
doing as much as you can in just that
little block and she says it's a game
changer she slides into the weekend
feeling better because she's crossed off
her list
one hour a week could you do it
okay
i want to try this you do how do you do
it i can't imagine you you do have lists
i'm trying to think i mean i never stop
yeah right like the energizer bunny in
bed at night like never never i mean i
i love this you do yes i do because if
you're a constant doer like or you're
totally lazy or anything in between i
think this could work for every type of
person because we all have those weird
things that we totally escape avoidance
and they just pile up and then they
fester and eat away at us like why am i
not doing that thing and you could just
attack it right then and there but you
don't so like two weeks later you're
like god that thing that thing
i this would drive me crazy i could
never do the
save it till friday i would think about
it monday tuesday wednesday third i
would think that i was gonna have to do
it on friday my mom always had lists she
had post-its everywhere at writing
everything down i have turned in to my
mother because every day i have a thing
next to me where i write things and if i
don't cross off the last thing i can't
go to sleep mm-hmm well you know how
much we talk about your mom here on the
show i know my mom you are the most
wonderful person and if you're anything
like your mother then obviously she's
the most wonderful well she was the most
wonderful person in the world and she
always got her list done too well who
here thinks this is an interesting
concept the needle list
you would do it
i just again i think it could speak to
the procrastinators and i think it could
speak to the doers because everybody
can't do everything and if you're really
bothered by the things you're not
getting done to block out one hour a
week very doable yeah but wouldn't you
think about it all week like i would
just dread friday all week long
no because i'm still doing a million
things until friday it's like for those
little things like i get that even the
word needle is like it just
right that that list
you're going to try it next week i saw a
lot of hands raising i think we should
try this and i love it on fridays
because it's true you go into the
weekend a little lighter okay i'll try
it if you try it i'm in anyone else want
to try it too all right
[Music]